he's an American entrepreneur venture
capitalists and hedge fund manager he
co-founded PayPal with Max Levchin and
Elon Musk he was ranked fourth on the
Forbes Midas list of 2014 at 2.2 billion
dollars he is Peter Thiel and here I has
stopped their rules for success
you are the entrepreneur of your life
and you can you can you can decide you
know what you're going to do what you're
going to prioritize and you should never
forget that you have a tremendous amount
of freedom as it is to make these very
basic decisions on what you're going to
do with your life and even start you can
start anytime you want the most critical
thing for every startup is to be doing
one thing uniquely well better than
anybody else in the world technology's a
fundamentally global business and the
really great technology companies are
doing something significantly better
than anybody else in the world and you
want to be in that sort of a position I
think if you're just starting a business
one of the questions it's always
valuable to answer is what do you know
that's true that nobody else understands
or more prosaically what what great
business exists that nobody is building
one part that I'm always I'm very
focused on is sort of the structure of
these companies and how well are people
aligned and so you can and making sure
that people are you know aligned
properly not just that they say I think
this is sort of a very very legal kind
of a framework to think about what are
people's incentives you know are they
going to be aligned or not and I think
you want to both have formal alignment
where you set the structure right and
you want to have informal alignment
where the people would naturally try to
work together well in one one way or
another
um and I think that's somehow tends to
get obscured in all these other ways um
you know there's always a there's always
a there's always a prehistory question I
like to ask founders of companies which
is how did you how did you meet what's
the
prehistory of the company before you got
started on tying that to be really
instructive set of questions to ask a
bad answer is something like you know we
met a week ago at a social networking
function at a business networking
function we decided to start a company
because we both wanted to be
entrepreneurs you know that's like
saying I married the first person I met
at the slot machines in Las Vegas and
you might hit the jackpot but it's
probably a really bad idea and a much
better answer is you know we've been
talking about this for a long time you
know maybe one of us is more on the tech
side the other one's more on the
business side we have these sort of
complementary skills and and so I think
this question of alignment and structure
is is incredibly important I think that
um all if yours founder or entrepreneur
what you want to aim for is monopoly you
want to aim to build a company that is
one-of-a-kind and that it's so far
differentiated from the competition that
it's not even competing and and I think
this is the conventional wisdoms always
the capitalism and competition are
somehow synonyms I believe they're
antonyms a capitalist is someone who's
in the business of accumulating capital
a world of perfect competition is a
world where all the profits are competed
away if you want to compete like crazy
then you should just open a restaurant
in Chicago and and and I think the the
great companies like Google so the
paradigm example I use has had no
serious competition in search since 2002
when it definitively distance itself
from Yahoo and Microsoft and as a result
it's been generating enormous cash flows
for the last 12 years yeah there
probably are a lot of people who who end
up trying to be sort of so much fake
entrepreneurs where the goal is to be an
entrepreneur um if you ask me what do
you want to do with your life what do
you want to when you grow up I want to
be an entrepreneur which I always think
is a somewhat too common something
disturbingly somewhat too common and I
think you know it's it's up it's on and
you know it's saying that you want to be
an entrepreneur is sort of like saying I
want to be rich I want to be famous you
know nobody in their right mind starts a
company for the sake of starting a
company
you start a company because there's a
very important problem to solve that's
not getting solved in large you know
governmental or nonprofit or for-profit
institutions and that's why you actually
need to start a new company just
starting a company for the sake of doing
so is a is a really odd thing to do on
an individual level I think it is always
it's always really good if if there's
something that you're incredibly
passionate about and and just sort of
our fine to be intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that and
so the you know one of the one of the
the resolutions I came up with a number
of years ago was to always value
substance over status substance over
prestige and you know if I sort of it
was giving my younger self advice on
what to what to do or how to how to
think about your ones one's life I you
know I probably I think I you know I
would probably still go to Stanford you
know I might still go to law school but
I'd ask
I'd ask sort of I'd ask a lot more
questions why why I was doing these
things and I think I think if I was
honest about it too much of it was
driven by by prestige and status and not
quite enough about really the substance
of trying to learn things and the other
heads for this I sort of think of it as
this sort of crazy rolling quarter life
crisis and sort of culminated in this in
this you know big New York law firm
where you know from the outside
everybody wanted to get in from the
inside everybody wanted to get out you
know after I lasted seven months and
three days and after and when I when I
when I left one of the people down the
hall said you know it's so reassuring to
see you leave Peter I had no idea was
possible to escape from Alcatraz which
which again and you know and again I and
all you had to do was go through the
front door but our identity people's
identities get so wrapped up and the
things they compete for that it was
inconceivable for people to actually do
that and and then the question was you
know well how had I ended up there why
had I not thought about that more
and and I think it was that I had taken
too many of these shortcuts of valuing
sort of what was prestigious what was
conventional over what I would I really
want to do so I think I think always
substance over status and this is why I
think competition is always this very
two-edged thing when you compete
ferociously you will get better at that
which you're competing on but you will
always narrow your focus to beating the
people around you and and it often comes
at this very high price of losing sight
of what is more important or perhaps
more valuable the general theme I would
suggest is that all trends are overrated
and so if you think about current trends
and technology you know healthcare IT
software education software overrated
SAS enterprise software really overrated
Big Data cloud computing if you hear
those words you need to think fraud you
need to run away as fast as you possibly
can and and the reason these buzzwords
um tell you that something is that
there's these buzzwords are sorta like a
tell in poker that people are bluffing
and that there's nothing that there's
that the business is not
undifferentiated because the buzzwords
tell you that it is one company of a
category that's undifferentiated from
the others in that category and
therefore are symptomatic somehow of a
lot of competition and a bad a bad
business idea and so you know you don't
want to be the fourth online pet food
company you don't want to be the tenth
thin-film solar panel company you don't
want to be the 1002 restaurant in San
Francisco and so there is something
about if you can describe what a company
is doing very straightforwardly by
referencing on these these buzzwords
these categories that already exist
that's actually a sign that it's a
pretty bad that's that's a pretty bad
idea I think there's a problem in in
Western Europe where where failure is
it's it's to impossible to fail once you
fail you can never you can
start over I think there's a there's an
opposite version of this in California
where I think sometimes people are a
little bit too facile about failure
because I I think it actually is always
incredibly damaging to people and if you
work really hard at something and it
doesn't work on that's you know that's
that's going to be psychologically
damaging you know people have less
confidence you know all sorts of reasons
why why that tends to be uh that tends
to be quite bad I think that I think
when people I don't think there's that
much you learn from failure by the way
because it's typically over determined
it's likewise technology slowing down
why did you fail it's typically five
separate reasons you worked with the
wrong people
the idea was bad the timing was wrong it
wasn't a monopoly the product didn't
work uh and okay next time I'm working
with different people you figure out one
out of the five things you're likely to
fail fail again so I think I think
failure is not something one can learn
very much from I think that's sort of a
myth that I I would challenge but what I
think what I think you should do when
you when something goes badly wrong is
you just keep going you do something
else uh and you don't dwell on the past
already in the time of Shakespeare the
word ape meant both primate and to
imitate and there is something very deep
in human nature that is imitative it's
how it has a lot of good things that's
how language gets learned by kids
it's how culture gets transmitted in our
society but it also can lead to sort of
a lot of insane behavior lead to the
madness of crowds to bubbles to to sort
of mass delusions of one sort or another
and and I think it can on and I think
it's you know advertising we always
think of we always tell ourselves that
were not that prone to this and I think
that's something I'd encourage all of us
to rethink and we always think of
advertising is something that just
afflicts other people that never plates
ourselves on I think this is very far
from the case and so and so the monopoly
competition is not just this
intellectual failure it's also this
thing where you have a tiny door where
everyone's trying to rush through and
there may be around the corner of
asked and a secret gate that no one's
taking and you should always find the
secret path and go ahead and take that
thank you guys so much for watching now
we made this video because chain Wang
Chung on YouTube asked Evan to make it
if you have a famous entrepreneur that
you really really really want Evan to
make a video on leave it in the comments
below I'd also love to know what you're
Peter Thiel's top ten rules hit you the
most leave it in the comments we're
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon